hey everyone it's sarah register
nursern.com and in this video i'm going
to demonstrate how to remove
a peripheral iv before performing any
nursing skills you want to make sure
that you're following your hospital's
protocols
to ensure you're following the latest
guidelines to perform this skill you'll
want to gather your supplies perform
hand hygiene and dawn gloves
the supplies you'll need will be gauze
tape and gloves
now i'm going to remove the iv and to
remove the iv
it's very simple we're going to remove
all the tape from the iv
first so we're just going to lightly
just tear this off
and this over here
and
you want to stabilize the iv as well
because you don't want to just rip that
out
okay once you have all your surrounding
tape
off you're going to take your gauze
and you are going to just put it over
here
because you're going to be sliding this
cannula out
so we're going to take everything and
grab and pull our cannula
in one smooth motion hold pressure
inspect your cannula make sure
everything is intact everything
looks great we're going to hold firm a
pressure for about two to three minutes
and you really want to hold pressure
because you don't want
blood to seep under their skin and cause
a nasty bruise
and this is especially true for patients
who are on anticoagulants you will
probably have to hold this even longer
and just make sure that it's firm
pressure
then dispose of this in the receptacle
area
that your facility requires you to
dispose these types of things in
then once you have held pressure for the
specific amount of time you want to just
lift up the gauze and make sure the side
is not bleeding anymore and our site
looks great
and what we're going to do is we're
going to take some tape
and we're just going to tape over the
gauze
and keep that like that and then what
we're going to do
is we're going to remove our gloves
perform hand hygiene and document that
we remove the patient's iv
okay so that wraps up this video and if
you would like to watch more videos on
nursing
skills you can access the link in the
youtube description below